commentaries bah-bah-bah talk
bla bla bla deleted scenes user comments
teasers for the next time you get a yeah
you've seen this before it's Godzilla
king of the monsters yeah I'm Spencer
Danielle on Jo Dan today we're talking
about Godzilla - electric Boogaloo yeah
a film that I think we all were various
states of whelmed by a little bit under
a little bit over but man we have
awakened a slumbering Titan now good
Godzilla Defense Force here's what I
think happened some of this moisture
because I review a lot of these movies
I'm on round 2 of almost everything we
get so I got this - when the movie came
out I think it's that the Godzilla fans
and it might review the movie I said if
you're a Godzilla fan if you love
Godzilla and all the movies you're gonna
love this movie and they did they were
super served which is great but I think
to people that maybe are not as big of a
fans of Godzilla and watch the movie
said like yeah I see Rodin came out of a
volcano but there's literally nothing
else happening in this movie that I can
connect to other than monster fighting
it doesn't speak to us as much which is
like it's it's it's the thing there has
to be two-way Road it's like I
acknowledge that if you're a Godzilla
fan I'm very happy that you like this
movie but you have to also acknowledge
that for those of us that maybe don't
care as much about Rodin King Ghidorah
punching each other maybe there's a
little less for us like a Bentley
hallows - was your first Harry Potter
movie yeah maybe yeah I didn't like this
film and I'm a huge Godzilla fan
there was no Matthew Broderick there was
no papa
I do I like a lot of think I'm not a
super fan but I like a lot of guns in
the movies but I feel like even them
some of the monster fights in this were
a little bit of a letdown it's a lot of
noise and debris and smoke and fire and
they're not necessarily like tight
that's something that's true of every
Godzilla movie but it's like he didn't
know where to put the camera like it was
like way too close or just obscured and
we recently had Godzilla or Kong Skull
Island which I thought did a much better
job like big supersized monsters
clobbering each other while also action
on the human scale yes
I just ever took but when something cool
happens it's like really cool just it I
feel like I did I didn't get enough of
the big cool moments like Mothra being
revealed and she's all like lit up and
pretty gorgeous you know when I like the
Rodin sequence when he's flying over the
village and like the whole city gets
ripped up there's a lot of great concept
art that was a phrase we were kicking
around his concept art the movie and
like this would have made an amazing
coffee table book of just like it was it
was like frames and then almost unmoving
still frames that you can pick from this
beautiful with a backlight yes sequences
are set pieces it's like shots and
moments like when Ghidorah lifts up its
wings of the electricity yeah but it's
not sustained this movie is 2 hours and
11 minutes long and you do not need that
much time to tell the Godzilla fighting
King Ghidorah story you just don't you
just I will talk more as we submit
ourselves to the honest trailer for
Godzilla 2 king monsters summit with
we're getting honest about summer
blockbusters past and present this is to
final all this tree
like Buster SunRail what an experienced
whirlwind may already be coming down you
love 2014's Godzilla did you actually
see Zilla
I like them now get ready for a sequel
that heard your demands and massively
over compensates boom Percy the movie
godzilla
pam more godzilla who has atomic breath
two thumbs and it's a movie title this
guy and he does have huh
now it appears from other from the
comments and what that we'll get to this
okay that we're complaining that there
is too much godzilla which we're not
know we're making a statement that there
was very little Godzilla in the last
movie now is this movie there's quite a
lot massively over compensate yes I
think that has like there's a nicer way
to phrase that I don't think we're being
perfectly neutral when they say they
massively overcompensate it's like it's
like oops all crunchberries like you
want you want a few crunchberries
factories screws up and elbows the liver
and the whole machine kicks it over so
there's just crunch berries it's too
much of a good thing well it is islands
to be said I don't think this movie
still a three hoops all tight there was
instead of very little monsters it was
all of them all of the answers in this
book I just want the placement also have
the director doing the Captain Crunch
like oh he's in the corner I think that
was Charles dance in this movie yeah
keep going
strap it for too long
keep trying to raise enough kites gonna
stop
that you can almost see when they're not
obscured by blizzards hiding behind
waterfalls submerged beneath the ocean
flying through debris and whatever is
happening here it's a Transformers
Godzilla forbid we see a monster fight
in the clear sunny day problem with any
of that with what I don't know I got it
all looks pretty cool like what do you
want
well again since I'm breaking down the
joke we point out that it's obscured and
then we'll show the alternative and we
say never mind
right so again well I was only bringing
a lot of baggage to this trailer even
handed cuz we're pointing out that this
is the technique that they really do use
put a lot of rain make it at night so
that you don't see the effects er
effects yeah and then when you don't do
that it's very obviously think you've
simplified for the sake of a joke I do
think the action in this movie is not
very well directed or shot or everyone
it hasn't promised that it's got it oh
it's but like even it's not so much like
a obscured or in inclement weather or
not thing cuz like Pacific Rim every
single fight is at night pretty much and
in the ocean or during the rain and the
fog or the rain or whatever but it looks
incredible and you can always tell
what's going on because you have
Guillermo del Toro and he knows where to
put the camera so you can tell what's
happening I just didn't get the same
vibe from this it was a lot of like it
kind of you're it's a little Cloverfield
II where you're a lot of so much the
action was from the ground level and
like over somebody's shoulder as there
so saying like while we were writing it
didn't it didn't make it in but it's
almost like they're doing turn-based
role-playing game fighting like one
monster attacks and then you kind of
wait and then the next monster powers up
and then it attacks it's like that's
just less dynamic and interesting than
like a fight like a more conventional
fight we're going just a Dragonball baby
they were going giant size Pokemon with
this because you have the whole premise
is like the the to the the ex-wife and
ex-husband like they both worked on a
device together that can control Titans
so you figure that they're both gonna
get that device and then be like
steering them against each other like
use like low pan and egg Shen in big
trouble
no China video games at each other dan I
choose you that'd have been awesome the
the biggest dropped ball of a third act
in a giant monster movie since rampage
when the rocks did not inject himself
with the monster large saving that one
for amazed that movie the best film ever
made I think that might have been one of
my favorite it was right there do you
think they cut it because like a
cannister lands next to the rock of
monster hormone and he's got he's teamed
up with the gorilla they're fighting the
lizard and the wolf right and then you
have like a big gorilla and then you
have the rock with the ability to become
as big as the crew so do you think a
test audience was like the rock cut - no
there was no Schneider cut of rampage
it's really thrown out in the writers
room they're like we gotta save
something for rampage to the rock and
then three people in monster suits like
a like a 70s I don't mind that even a
little instantly vaulted into the
greatest monster movie ever made but
yeah that's neither here nor there let's
keep watching this dumb one at particle
effects spend the rest of your time with
the humans of the movie look I'm really
sorry guys
we kind of have to featuring the
Russell's your typical nuclear family
mom is a genocide or maniac and dad is a
professional animal listen to ER follow
their time-tested love story as boy
meets girl boy and girl make by rhythmic
acoustic device to talk to whales
Godzilla eats their son I think girl
reapplies will take to control kaiju boy
gets drunk and lives with dwarfs and
Tony Stark's cabin girls leaves them
with ego terrors to awaken an ancient
space monster boy ups nuke rival earth
monster to enhance its power and all
right hold up all that stuff happens in
this movie how is it still so boring
pathos for those who have said and I've
seen it it's just like well there was
giant monsters fighting and movie what
more do you want
exactly 75% of this movie was this dumb
thing about a computer that talks to
animals and the humanities the real
enemy and pointless other garbage about
like isn't that if people complained
about in the last movie I think the
human character and it's a weird hard
balance to figure out cuz you gotta have
people on beings and movie they can't
there their conflict can't be can't be
like directly tied into it has to like
run parallel like Kong Skull Island it
was like we have to get off the island
while the monsters are fighting and
hopefully we don't end up being
collateral damage of the monster
fighting like I get that and then you
have the whole heart of darkness thing
that Sam Jackson does which is cool this
movie if you I was thinking about if you
took out the whole Orca thing this movie
would still happen pretty much exactly
the same because the point of Godzilla
is to like keep balance I don't think
they keep trying to give a Dean deal I'm
into the joy
stupid okay yeah no he just wants
everything to be perfectly balanced so
if that's the case in the other but then
Ghidorah is an alien thing that keeps
everything off balance they're gonna
fight anyway so just make them wait like
you don't need the orc just cut the
organ they all wake up and I just had
Charles dance be the driver of the plot
he's the one who releases the monsters
and then the family and monarch has to
stop and like the whole veer Formiga
betrays them and then untraced and
convoluted and that's the difference for
me between the first Godzilla movie and
this one I liked the last Godzilla movie
and it did also have a lot of humans in
it but the thing that I that kept me on
this board was it was contained it was
about Aaron taylor-johnson he's trying
to get back to his family you're
following him for most of the movie so
at least when you go back to the human
characters I'm following a story yeah
this movie is like you're following 15
human characters I don't care about any
of them and every scene is another
version I think looking at screens and
going like oh I think it's like Charles
dance is the bad guy that wakes up
Ghidorah all hell starts breaking loose
and the good folks of Monarch have to go
into the Hollow Earth to wake up
Godzilla after he gets beat up like
that's not your plot 90 minutes in and
out animal talk or tour yeah you don't
need the weird family dynamics or mr.
Anderson
humanity is the virus like you don't
need any I don't think you don't need
her doing like a PowerPoint presentation
about her evil plan that's my favorite
part but do you appreciated that she
took the time to say like look this is
why I've betrayed you multimedia
president
disease they won't listen but if I show
them this file footage then they'll be
yeah when my wife leaves me I hope it is
via Skype and a perfectly safe it's fine
I get it
girlfriend Keep Calm never ever be some
horse a cast with six Emmys and five
Oscar nominations between them tackles a
big-budget sharknado where Sally Hawkins
is killed off in the blink of an eye and
she's been Watanabe impression sake
Godzilla as many times as he can before
dying
coach Coach Manny doesn't get those and
Charles dance is also present
we'll take you leaving brilliant actors
with nothing to do but track down giant
monsters fell to track and study
Godzilla on his own turf it allows us to
trick you we lost Godzilla dropped off
the skin near Venezuela on sex is
tracking and when they find them stare
like a fraternal stares as we do this in
the last Godzilla movies so is it
appropriate staring
[Music]
I mean they got great faces to stare
yeah yeah the cats a great staircase
mm-hmm dramatic obvious when did dance
turn prestige was a Tywin because I mean
he was the bad guy in the golden child
alien 3 alien 3 yep he probably does
like Hamlet every year dance or B movies
because that's my jam but yeah he was
coming over here and doing Last Action
Hero and then going back to DC and doing
drama
ready to take up like what was the
turning point where people were like
this is below Charles for American
audiences it's definitely time okay yeah
can we also say is this a good point to
point out that nobody noticed it took me
three times through the movie the Z
Zhang is playing twins yeah they cut
that out because slide and when she's
showing through her family history I'm
like everyone is twins right like well
there's two scenes where they give it
away one is they cut two Joe Morton and
his separate team that are at the Mothra
site and she's there but it's it's dr.
Ling Dr Chen's twin sister but then the
next time we see dr. Chen yes she has a
photograph where there's three
generations of her family they've all
worked for monarch and they're all falls
sets of twin which is a nod to like the
original Mothra stories of like they're
the two miniature twins it's not good
yeah give me the two little ladies that
sing Mothra you existence listings of
that like floating plotline makes me
think there was probably a lot of stuff
that got cut all backstories to suffer a
lot of these characters and that's why
maybe it seems like Paige is kind of
like Sally Hawkins probably there was a
sea you needed more time tracking yeah
track or tune what time to track how are
we gonna find these skyscrapers sighs
must have a to see where they were like
wow Sally Hawkins dead that's sex
because she's in the first move there
were there was a beat it wasn't a scene
but there was a beat when they're all
like and then you see it tells me how
fast she got killed off that they had to
like zero in on a screen with her face
that said deceased and then like they
don't really spend time on it but Ken
Watanabe is definitely bummed that's a
moment of being bummed out and he's like
they have to find Godzilla they gave it
enough for me
I've if there's like the main part in
character in the middle of this movie
the 10-minute Tony Stark level funeral
earth shape of water
jeremy renner to show up and yell you
can use the orca you I ask you that
every slasher movie stopped and had a
funeral for everyone that got stabbed
like I don't need that for the modern
action movie where the villain wants to
destroy humanity in order to save the
earth then underwhelmed audiences and
disappointed at the box-office pause all
right the man comes around pointing two
things number one audiences people like
excuse me the Rotten total score is 82%
which i think is rich because any time
anybody has a movie that they don't want
to talk to the audience core about like
why Jedi are captive arms like Rotten
Tomatoes all you score means nothing
that's garbage it's rigged and it's a
sham but when they want it to be good
they're like well this has a good
audience score on Rotten Tomatoes so I
think it's funny how people can use the
facts depending on whether they want to
agree with them or not that's hilarious
but if you want to have that argument
that's fine but I've seen it was like it
is an objective fact that it did not
disappoint at the box-office no it's not
and I'll tell you why Godzilla made 520
in the 2014 movie made five hundred
twenty-nine million dollars worldwide
King Kong's Kong Skull Island 566
million dollars worldwide Godzilla king
of the monsters made three hundred
eighty five million dollars worldwide so
just from a point of view it dropped 144
million dollars from the first movie the
dropped 181 million dollars from the
last movie franchise that is a
disappointment it had a 170 million
dollar budget 385 million dollar gross
that's just barely over double the
budget which double the budget is the
possible bare minimum but really it's
closer to three time because you don't
only have 170 million dollar budget
you've got at least 100 million dollars
of our promotional marketing fees on top
of that so by that metric not a good
performance regret so let's king the
monsters secondly domestically Godzilla
make two hundred million dollars
domestically Colm 868 million dollars
domestically king of monsters made 110
domestically so domestically is the
lowest-grossing and you get more from
the studio from a domestic release about
50% you get way less foreign so a lower
domestic gross even if it makes a good
amount for and meat you don't get as
much coming back so yes office
you don't Wow by this man yeah they
stopped down wow wow I hope you tracked
down whatever seventeen-year-old said
that and safe to its face disappointment
objectively as I okay
Zillah straight facts all right let's
keep gondola versus Kong is already in
production the franchise is literally
too big to fail we're giving it no
matter what the real Elba is corporate
inertia story clear eyes full hearts hi
choose typical Chi Jewish mother
Titan team go an old man filled with
regret waiting to die alone why didn't
somebody sponsors and the very different
aura respect the original and put her in
a tiny seashell given Godzilla third
movie hail Hydra come my lady come come
my lady you're a butterfly
Mothra baby Mexico Wild Wings cc's the
franchise building need these things are
there seventeen and the bear from the
shining what what is wrong with this
family
yeah as weird positive oh yeah the shots
like exactly and they've even given him
like whiskers to live mouth yes because
there should have been a reveal like
Kyle channel and be like you took away
my kids after everything fell apart and
I had to go to the woods the Liceo balls
tell you
and then there's the reveal that like
know you used to play shining bear with
the kids and that's why we left
listening in no play we can work in one
of the one of the comments right here
ssj enforcer wrote please stop referring
to it as the bear from the shining it's
a dog costume in the book well it is a
bear in the movies it's a it's like a
visual callback to the bear that Danny
has with them in the beginning so for
whatever reason
Kubrick changed it from a doctor I mean
look at that's a bear like that's I mean
it doesn't seem if you take if you take
the mask off maybe maybe it's bar from
Spaceballs it is being played by John
Candy yes credited mm-hmm in the book -
okay you're right bear in the body so
it's ambiguous at best in them also the
hedge maze are like head sculptures and
they come to life in the book that that
doesn't happen in the movie it is
literally a Danny has a bear with him in
the opening scenes that's like whenever
and it's a it's a metaphor or the
subjugation of actual abuse for Jack's
character so it's even darker yeah so by
accident made of his paper film
objectively not so different
yep mm-hmm I've heard that yeah Benny
much like a turn let them fight club
that's good he says that yeah not in
fact they can all admit oh my science
knowledge because we're watching
Chernobyl
yeah yeah my my Boston that's like
really really bad right well not just
bye-bye Boston but they they go into the
cave and like you can watch a Nabi the
whole thing with him is that he was
never gonna come out anyway because
Godzilla was so hotly radioactive yeah
that you couldn't even be in the same
project with drones that break down
immediately due to the high radiation
and then they nuke him with an actual
nuclear weapon and then like five
minutes later Millie Bobby Brown is
standing like a foot away from him as
he's walking or like you they're all
gonna like develop like carcinoma so I
don't know there was clearly graphite on
the ground see I can avoid coefficients
or a problem this is like the weird
challenge I think of a Godzilla
franchises because in the original
franchise it's literally a metaphor for
atomic warfare and Japan having to
rebuild as an eighth like so it it works
and you don't get so much caught up in
the fact that every three weeks Godzilla
shows up it smashes the city because
like that's the metaphor but for this
stuff it's like no he's benevolent he's
here to protect us and the Fisher
repopulating cuz he's here but also very
radioactive but a hero role the nukes
and it's like but what they imply I
think is that his radiation was actually
good and so yeah right I'm never going
back back human humankind underground so
that the earth well no but like in the
end credits they're like everywhere
explains it as part of her theory like
the Titans will attack but then once in
their path new life will grow they're
like the forest spirit from spirited
away
Mononoke just the movie has like an
ethos it's like you know the strong are
the alphas and everyone else boughs down
and like the natural order underneath
them which is based on and I'll go a
mini rant here bad wolf science yes yes
Kyle Chandler wolf scientist in this
movies like he's the Alpha he's
challenging them for the alpha male
status and then everyone else will be
the beta and all you baby Huffington
guys this is based on bad wolf science
Paddington bears people who use alpha
and beta on ironically this is all based
on Studies on wolves in captivity the
scientist who did it who popularized it
in a book has spent the rest of his
entire career saying I got it wrong
there's no alpha wolf there are no
alphas and betas in wolf's families that
in the wilderness it's a different
social structure and wolves form little
families of a mom and dad and children
and that's the hierarchy it's not oh
there goes the alpha wolf oh so all of
you know regretable wolf tattoos cover
it up there are no alphas what pill am I
supposed to take its just mashing
together okay just snort it so now this
is a white boy like we thought okay okay
anyways the bad Wolf's I don't even like
he's in those words ironically although
I would watch a movie called wolf
scientists
both sides open for Wolfmother a good
coffee shop - what are the deleted
scenes but since Godzilla vs. Kong is
our production the franchise is
literally too big to fail we're getting
it no matter what
xi does cutting edge monster research
instead of going to school or spending
any time with literally anyone her own
age
it's just a kid problem because godzilla
forbid we see a monster fight on the
clear sunny day that without nevermind
let's all slink back to the darkness
where it looks better no storm is that
fast unless it's not a storm that's
consider that'll work story and reach
earth the Chi Chi weaned tighten with my
family 12 rah al ghul who didn't want to
not be in the series any means dr.
grambs NASA's Hayden run but I'm Titan
Lannister Raiders of the monarch the
only guy who realizes what kind of movie
he's in what's a tunnel into the hollow
relationship but guilt not ones and
talkin bout regeneration though Fast and
the Furious
get ready godzilla deploy all monsters
wait a second if the mom really make a
PowerPoint presentation to cellar evil
plan using delorca we will return to it
a full-on order we coexisted in balance
with the Titans and that's why everyone
on earth deserves to die all right thank
you for coming to my TED talk it's it's
him he's the one doing this if Joe
Morton plays a scientist in your movie
things are definitely gonna go very
poorly what a weird way to get typecast
yeah technological project he plays it
well all right let's check out some of
y'all's comments sorry I'm going to
print them out I'm not checking my phone
we addressed that Ryu spike writes
disappoint audiences isn't very accurate
can saying audience reviews tend to be
extremely positive well
B+ cinema school class cinema score
which is okay but for this kind of movie
you've won a little bit higher it's it's
okay but not great yeah
there's a highly anticipated summer
movie that kind of fizzled out I feel
like there people like this more than a
leader I'd have to say Kuya Jay writes
critics of Godzilla be like monsters
critics of Godzilla king of monsters
quote not enough humans look like
Godzilla's purpose is to restore balance
you can find a balance just this movie
could have been 90 minutes long and I
think I would have liked it 90 times
didn't say we clearly know we're in the
trailer said we wanted more humans we
even have a joke about how we have to
spend time with humans I don't know
where that that was not the completion
just the ratio was off there's to it it
was a big long movie so there was more
Godzilla and more humans in this I think
he could have scaled back on one more so
than the other just streamlined it
fights to be tighter tighter more
tighter and more exciting I would have
been more in nothing I know problem 2
fights they just every time they cut
away from them I was completely
disengaged there were a few moments
where you were the pro-wrestling phantom
you got when Mothra shows up to save
Godzilla I audibly cheered at my at my
screen because I just heard Stone Cold
Steve Austin's glass break
but it's not a cool fight or scene
it's right the entrance is cool yeah it
didn't seem fair to throw my throat in
there which is kind of modern-day vwe I
guess there no just something about a
moth seems very easy to kill as the
massive standard are not happy with yeah
all right movie buff combo right I
thought this film you have but one
regret and it's that I am i I thought
this film was a cinematic experience
that's not that's not inaccurate that's
not every time you go to a movie theater
you are max it is it is
I imagine that you could do I would love
to do a reverse director's cut I want to
see a studio cut this movie where they
trim this down to just the best stuff
and just the IMAX fighting play did see
the studio cut and play seven nation
army enter more lots more needle drops
TIFF Studios being like we need you need
to give them a kid give them the kid and
we need like like an evil scientist -
yeah but it's like we need to have the
kid be like oh mom or dad like you need
to ground it like a family's people then
relate to that know there's been like a
visual album Beyonce style firmeza the
idea that someone was like relatable
family tale and they were like okay
Janice Idol mom who wants to bring back
the natural order and a dad who leaves
them in a drunken haze to go listen to
wolves you know family stuff yeah Brown
she's just there to go mom sometimes dad
mom yeah don't get comfortable and
that's it for y'all's comments um the
other one was about the dog costume man
otherwise everybody was like you guys
dude personal otherwise everything goes
for that it rushed it once again
as we always do we should tease before
we go oh wait oh yeah you see orders of
business number one if you'll check last
week I thought next week was this week
so look for last week's clue for this
week that makes sense right
next week's clothes masking on we're
working on the one for next week yeah
well we were filming this show last yeah
buddy so when he did it wrong I did it
wrong yeah so just look at that one
and then also sharp-eyed viewers they
didn't find the hidden alan in 508 no
they yeah which there was a hidden alan
in 500 days there is not one in this
unless account Godzilla yeah Godzilla
was the hidden now yeah just just a
whoops just a whoops hey you it's
probably cuz there's so many Allen
looking creatures in this then the Rodin
was a minor oversight I believe you have
a clip of where I think that first
deleted scene was that we showed was
where I wanted to put it really was the
I didn't say is that correct that first
lead it seems it's got two squares
already in production the franchise is
literally too big to bear yes thank you
Kevin he was very very I was really
frustrated that they forgot himself up
over it so there's the Allen in our
hearts and mind battling sort of to
Godzilla yeah the Allen Allen is really
the king of all yeah yeah
Allen boughs to no alpha
it's like Frodo yeah you bout to know
all about and that's all now next week
you're gonna love it
alright
[Music]
you